Can physical vibration of a cancerous tumor also help trigger the immune system to attack
the cancer?
I thought of this based on the right frequency vibrates in the tumor.
Yeah, I think that's very possible.
The only thing you'd have to be careful about with physical vibration, we're talking it
with the right.
It's a vibration at a cellular point.
If you did physical vibration, like using a handheld vibrator over a pancreatic cancer, you could
irritate things as well, though if you did it a little bit farther away, not directly
over it, it could help stimulate lymphatic flow.
That's the idea of using like that, the bouncy thing that people bounce on for rebounder,
to get the lymphatic drainage going, and there's benefits to that.
So yes, I would just be careful directly over a cancer with...
I was thinking because I just did a three-day motorcycle trip where the bike vibrates all
day long, we're on the road most of the day, and then afterwards I noticed some distinct
differences, like a little bit more blood in my stool and other things.
So it just struck me that maybe something like that is happening, that's why I asked.
Maybe?
Yep, it's...
I mean, you could just have some physical irritation to that too.
So I'm not saying that this is certainly always a bad thing, but you get some flow going
with the hat.